hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where if you don't know me I
work at Sony Santa Monica Studio and we
just released God of War Ragnarok we had
this big kind of launch party
technically two launch parties a launch
party and then a wrap party at the
office and they gave everybody the
yotnar Edition as well as two other
things they got this which was like a
wrap gift in this bag
and then this bag um which got wet
because it was really rainy that is the
holiday gift so I thought that I'm gonna
unbox the Yota edition first but then
also show you the other cool gifts that
the studio gave us I have no idea what
these things are so starting with the
Yoda Edition I actually haven't looked
at this since it was announced by
marketing so I don't even um remember
what exactly this is involved also sorry
if there's background noise there is a
desk being built upstairs there's that
logo all right okay
out of the box
you can help me please help me get it
out of the boat stitches
nice one all right I knew the box was
big it still somehow um bigger than I
expected it's huge and beautiful it does
say everything that's in it on the back
but I'm not going to pay attention to
that so it's all fresh when I open it
already looks so cool
very nice
here is the Box
big and beautiful
oh my gosh it's like actual bits of
fabric I apologize for it every time but
I have never had a good Unboxing Setup
and that has not changed today clearly
we're on my floor all right
[Music]
it's a shrine
oh my gosh
triptychs as they're called
how beautiful how unnecessarily
beautiful that's the coolest part it
didn't need to look this nice but it
does pull this out
Tada oh that's neat this actually comes
off
I might like display that somewhere I
might just take that out and put it in
my office somewhere oh let's open this
up probably
it's pretty sturdy
very nice it's also like very cool
seeing this in person because Eric
Williams the director of God of War
Ragnarok had a prototype of this sitting
on his desk that we would often see in
meetings like above and you're right
buddy that we would often see in
meetings um like other any video
conference calls so I've seen it in
various stages from Eric's desk
foreign
painted for sure which is always awesome
it's like nice nice actual
sort of leather down here too which is
really cool hell yeah
how cool
I love it the rest of it sits on the top
here this was all just below so let's
open this up
all right
got this little Satchel here which I
I'm assuming has Brooks die based on it
feeling like dice
so we've got
rocks die here
there are
a bunch of them
these also look hand painted
which is again always lovely
very pretty
we have the steelbook
which is absolutely beautiful this comes
with two codes no discs the future so
we've got
the Kratos risen snow Alma
which I actually really like the digital
content is the full game for PS4 and PS5
which is really cool I like that they
give both
PlayStation 4 theme Avatar Set Dark
Horse digital mini art book official God
of War Ragnarok digital soundtrack
Kratos darkdale armor darkdale x-script
ducktail blade handles and atreus
darkdale attire cosmetic
beautiful then we have these two little
carvings here which I believe are the
vaniant twins
all right
I do have a Kratos and atreus wood
carvings too these are gonna look so
nice
sitting next to them on a shelf how
pretty also before people get mad at me
for my nails which they always do I
don't care enough
I write for a living it's hard to type
if you have fake nails and I don't bite
my nails they just break they're just
flimsy all right I believe there is more
oh this is such a cool layout
I love these
how awesome is that dude the Falcon the
bear and the Wolf how awesome and like
such iconic parts of the game these are
really solid as well oh my God I love
these
like they're just this is beautiful
damn okay more things I gotta display
next appears to be a cloth map oh this
is gorgeous
but man the the artists of Santa Monica
Studio are mind-blowingly talented
I mean everyone is but
they just blow my mind all the time a
bunch of like imagery of things that
happen in the game too obviously
absolutely gorgeous
not sure what this is oh
this is the uh drop near ring
there you go
a ring is that there's no way that's
gonna fit on any of my fingers not even
my thumb it's huge
nice detail on the inside
it's like very textured as well
beautiful
on the back it says music by Ben McCurry
a Sun's poth and giantess of Ironwood
that's uh it's so similar to
the God of War 2018 one too which is
very cool this is so pretty
beautiful a lot of animal themes in this
game if you haven't played it
warning in advance
it's sad alright that is the Yoke knob
Edition unboxed which is so so so
beautiful I wasn't sure if the studio
would send me one I didn't know if I
would get one or not
um and when they sold out really fast I
was worried but it looks like we got him
which is awesome
and I'm gonna have to display all of
this in my office
because of course
okay that's back in the box now let's do
the rap gift this little bag right here
no idea what's in it but it looks like
we have
a copy of God of War Ragnarok launch
edition on the PlayStation 5. you might
ask Eric to sign that actually might
take that into the office next time I go
in and ask him to sign it that would be
cool yeah
the opt
of God of War Ragnarok
very early scene
at the start there how beautiful
bunch of art on the back I'm sure
there's tons of concept art
it says follow Kratos and atreus journey
across the nine Realms alongside the
creators of God of War Ragnarok the
sequel to 2018's lauded action adventure
we'll just do a quick flip through and
maybe I just won't show you this in
general to make sure that we avoid
spoilers but uh
it's pretty we have
God of War uh Ragnarok Edition lanyard
we have whatever this is
mysterious no idea
oh that's so cool
oh I love this okay I'm gonna have to
give context for this
so um ah it's a magnet too this is
awesome so the studio has this wall that
you might have seen if you follow anyone
who works at Santa Monica Studio
where there are a bunch of employees
faces and characters faces in these
little like square blocks as well as
game covers and the first thing that
Eric did when we were in the office for
the
launch party
was take the square which looked just
like this the God of War Ragnarok and
put it on that wall That's the tiles of
everybody's faces so what this is is a
smaller version of the tile that's in
the office as a magnet that I will put
on my fridge or I don't know probably
keep somewhere a little bit safer
because this is very very cool it's
really need to have a smaller version of
the one that's in the office and was
like planted on the wall uh just a
couple of days ago that is awesome love
that
okay what is this God of War Ragnarok
decal sheet with seven stickers okay got
some stickers for us
how awesome super high quality
love that how beautiful
I feel like I should put these on my
work computer I wonder what this is
another little thing that says go to a
Ragnarok oh this is a keychain Okay so
uh how cool
so obviously this little plot here says
go to Thor Ragnarok with some blue
accents and this is the Leviathan ax how
awesome that's so so neat oh this is
also cool so the walls thing in here
I've been able to see this whole time
and I'm assuming that I know what it is
because it sure looks like a PlayStation
controller which is another thing that
I'm very glad I got because it's sold
out so fast I was like no I don't want
to miss out
it is this is the limited edition God of
War Ragnarok Jewel sense controller
which
um I'm being honest I'm probably never
going to use I will sit it on my shelf
with a couple of my other
sort of collectible controllers that I
have
this is beautiful
I love the color it's so pretty
wow
yeah I'm gonna display it for sure
isn't that gorgeous
I love the Dual sense in general
um
but yeah don't think I'm gonna be using
this one we'll just keep it
very pretty obviously says the game name
on the back the wheel logos
I love it I love it I love all of it
it's also cool okay so that was
everything that was in bag one bag two
is the holiday gift which is separate to
the wrap gift they give us Christmas
gifts every year so that's what this bag
here has in it which is like a sack I
have no idea what this is I'm only
assuming
you see it has my name and says my
department which is design I'm on the
design team and then says M which makes
me think that
they needed my t-shirt size for some
reason so we'll see if there are shirts
in here
[Music]
it is a bag
first okay we have another t-shirt
oh wow that's awesome it says design
team on it that's my first one of those
I have a Dev team shirt but I don't have
a design team shirt
that's so cool that's me I wonder if all
the different departments have different
logos probably not I don't know they do
go pretty all out but
that's uh that's the coolest it's such a
nice place to work it's like it's crazy
and then this is the bag
which I guess is Ogio Ogio
and it says Santa Monica Studio right on
the front there this is a pretty hard go
back to be honest kind of like that
something about it makes it look like a
PlayStation logo like not the logo but
it kind of looks like a PS1 something
about the design of this I don't know
maybe I'm nuts how cool is that is
everything this is the best
I'm so stoked
um and so happy to
have the game out and I've been watching
people play it I wanted to wait a little
bit before I made any kind of content
because I just want to make sure that um
I don't do it before other people do
like I way prefer that you watch other
content creators who don't work at the
studio unboxing on our Edition and all
that stuff so
I wanted to wait to let everybody else
do it first and then I think that I will
upload probably a let's play of the
first hour which is all I'm going to do
maybe this weekend obviously I've played
through the first hour of the game I
don't know six seven times
so I don't really know what I'm gonna
say I can maybe comment on some things
that
had changed in a small capacity without
breaking NDA obviously but uh thank you
all for watching
me just all you really watch was just me
just be delighted for however long I've
been recording this for because this is
all so cool and maybe I'll take um I'll
take an updated photo if I have like
this God of War shelf in my office
that I'll have to like find nice places
to fit all this new stuff in which is
very cool
also The cookbook I don't remember the
release date now but I actually worked
on the God of War cookbook the official
cookbook you can find some stuff I wrote
in there so I will leave a link in the
description if you want to check that
out I think I made my whole family
pre-order it I'm excited to get my hands
on that too
um thank you all for watching I'm Alana
and I will see you guys next time bye